but first it's been a difficult first
week of the German election campaign for
the Conservatives but this morning
they're trying to get back on the front
foot because they've produced a dossier
saying that a Labour government would
cost the country 1.2 trillion pounds
over five years but not everyone is
convinced about the figures joining us
now to try and get to the bottom of this
is the conservative business minister
quasi quante thank you very much for
being on the program today
so this 1.2 trillion figure is splashed
on the front pages many newspapers this
morning I mean it sounds a ridiculous
sum of money it's a huge is it actually
right what's going on project fair no
well what's happened is that we've
simply added up all the labor policies
in terms of their costings
they're going to nationalize renal eyes
energy water gas companies they've got
proposals to give grants for people to
increase the energy efficiency of their
homes they're talking about a four-day
week now a four-day week working week
sounds great but it has to be paid for
and if you add up all the some of their
policies you get to a huge amount of
money 1.2 trillion which is the amount
that would be required to fund the NHS
for nine years you said in these
policies you say to these labour
policies yeah as far as I'm aware labour
hasn't publish its manifesto yet well
they're coming from well last week
you'll remember in the middle of last
week John McDonald said I think was a
400 billion national infrastructure fund
and at that time he said this was an
unprecedented mountainous and the 1.2
trillion and I'm asking where are these
policies from because labour hasn't
published a manifesto so a large portion
of them are from the 2017 manifesto
which they are committed to and other
things the policies that they've they've
stated in the course of the last two
years they've spoken about the four-day
week that's something which is out there
it's public and we've know if that's
gonna be the manifesto they do but they
have stated in the last two years
various policies like the universal
basic income all those things are going
to have to be paid for and Labour's
policies I'm afraid don't add up in this
area I mean some of the policies that
you're costing as well are things that
were passed at conference and we know
that not everything that was passed a
conference may work its way into the
manifesto I mean talk about private
schools for example
I know from interviewing people that
that may very well not end up in the
manifesto so why don't you at least wait
until we know what's definitely going to
be on the table before you work this out
I think it's very important that when
people make statements about what their
policies are what sorts of things they
want to give to the electorate it's very
important that we have scrutiny and if
it was a government you would scrutinize
rightly those figures and that's what
we've done to the to the labor part that
we've shown that they are reckless in
their spending it's a huge amount of
money that the country can't afford it's
something like 40,000 pounds for every
household extra in terms of debt and
this is just not a credible policy who's
done this research I think people in
central office and also independent
independent can you guarantee that no
taxpayer money has been put into
spending this analysis and the reason
I'm asking is because there were reports
that mark said well the cabinet
secretary actually blocked the
publication of costings have labor
policies so you're quite right to say
that mark said well blocked the costings
from the civil service and that's why
we've had got a separate separate
analysis and on that point you will
remember that in previous elections
governments have always I've been Gordon
Brown did this certainly in 2010 they've
always costed the opposition parties
manifestos and that's quite a legitimate
thing for their policies their policy
it's entitled and this is why we've done
this independently but look we can't
have politicians going around promising
the earth promising huge amounts of
spending without some rigorous analysis
of how much it's going to cost and who's
going to foot the bill okay so what's
your rigorous analysis and of all of the
spending pleasures and how much a
conservative government would cost if
Boris Johnson has wins the election well
we made an announcement that we're going
to spend a bit more we're going to spend
how much because you've got this really
good round figure for labour 1.2
trillion
what's the figure for the concept so the
infrastructure spending we were going to
do was 150 billion that was in the title
no single bits of policy about the take
that was that was the the broad the
broad figure and it was a much lower
figure than the one that John MacDonald
boasted about which was 400 billion
alone on national infrastructure that's
even for that 2/3 of the 1.2 trillion
and that's
we've got to the one point so that's
structure spending from the parties but
what's the total conservatives so so
what we're trying to do is do 3 percent
of GDP on infrastructure spending and
we're going to spend more money on
police which is the right thing to do
and we're going to spend a lot more
money on the NHS but our sums and not
anything is astronomical and as huge as
the labor supplies they can't because
they can't be they can't be costed and
I've and we I was we were announced 84
billion last year extra for the NHS by
the end of the 2022 period as we thought
it was then we've already announced more
spending increases and that comes on the
back of actually being prudent being
sensible about public finances I'm just
a bit confused that you know
conservative campaign headquarters and
spent all this time working out this
exact sum for labor they've gone through
all of the spending commitments as you
say they've got this nice big number and
yet you can't tell me what the
equivalent numbers for the concert we
had a budget last year which says the
the Parliament so all those figures
interests about the next partner in the
last year we had a we had a budget and
that's what governments do governments
have budgets where they set out spending
policies the reason why we've costed the
opposition's manifesto is that
opposition's can get away with it they
all our opposition policies that they
can get away with this these things they
can promise the earth without any real
rigorous look at actually how much
they're going to spend and where the
money is going to come from and that's
what we've done it is absolutely right
that we did say it's absolutely right
that the public know that Labour's plans
are reckless and are affordable
you haven't got equivalent number for
the Conservatives have you we do we do
have a number well as I've said we're
spending 150 billion more in
infrastructure we're going to spend a
lot more money on I'm not gonna be
around figures for neighbors but that's
there I mean that's our job is to scrape
this to scrutinize what labor are doing
with a genuine decision it's absolutely
right
for us to say this is what the
opposition is saying and this is how
much it's going to cost as I've said to
you we had a budget last year in which
we set out very clearly what our
spending commitments while anyone could
see that does the government want to
promote we are going to borrow it a
little bit more that's what Sajid Javid
said but that's on the back there's
always a context in these things that's
on the back of actually making really
good and tough decisions in the last
nine years where we actually didn't grow
public spending as much as many people
wanted to see because we couldn't afford
it we came in in 2010 with a record
deficit 160 billion pounds and at the
moment we've pretty much balanced the
books and now we're saying after this
long period we could afford to spend a
bit more money on vital public services
you really pretty much passed the back
time we're still spending tens of
millions of pounds on debt we are in
2010 twelve percent of our entire
economy was borrowed money in terms of
debt it was 160 billion pounds easy to
forget and that was a peacetime record
we have substantially reduced that and
now we're in a position where we feel
rightly in my view that we can spend
more on vital public services
okay well let's have a look shall we on
whether or not that message is coming
through because Sky News has teamed up
with you go for this election we're
doing a bit of polling as the campaign
goes just to find out how some of these
messages are landing and this week we
asked people if the conserved has formed
a government after the election do you
think they would spend more less or
about the same as now on public services
so 30 percent think that you will spend
a bit more which is what you've been
saying to us but 27 percent think you'll
serve on the same 23 percent less and 23
percent say they just don't know I mean
is this a bit of a worry your message
clearly isn't getting through to people
I think I think well let's take the
facts first I mean the plurality more
people think that we're going to spend
more than the other columns compared to
well it's 30 percent compared to 27
percent but well compared to what 70
percent but look at the beginning of the
campaign you're quite right I think
we've got a real job and that's why it's
a hard-fought campaign that's why we
have campaigns so that we can get the
message out and five weeks out from the
election
we're gonna have to increase increase
those numbers and tell people that we
are actually willing to spend more on
vital public services I mean is that the
problem that you've really spent nine
years talking about austerity and it's
going to take a long time isn't it for
people to realize for the messages to
come through that austerity is oh I
don't think it's a problem and you've
said that austerity is over and I think
you're quite right we're gonna spend
more money but the main central question
of this election is obviously the brexit
issue because there's no way we're going
to get to more spending get a firmer
stronger policies without resolving this
issue this brakes at issue which has
dogged the last Parliament the last
Parliament was completely useless
frankly it couldn't get any resolution
on this and the reason why the Prime
Minister wants an election is that he
wants a parliament that's actually gonna
work for people resolve brexit and then
we can have a debate about public
spending and about how we get the best
public services in this country talking
about brexit and Nigel France the brexit
Party leader has been talking about
standing candidates in many seats across
the country if not all seats across the
country he doesn't think that Boris
Johnson sprits it till it is really
bright said are you worried as a fellow
leave Nigel Franz in the brexit party
may effectively stop brexit from being
done and what would be your message to
him look I would say to Nigel he you
know he was a big big part of the fact
that we voted to leave he's had a
political success I think that now is
the time for him really to step aside so
that we've got a government a clear
message it's obvious to a lot of people
perhaps not as many as we'd like but
it's obvious to many people but the only
way we're gonna get brexit done is by
voting for a Conservative government
Boris Johnson has negotiated against
everyone's expectations he negotiated a
deal it's ready to go and if we get a
majority we'll be able to land the deal
and leave the EU by the end of January
I'm I just want to ask a little bit of
detail on the brexit deal that's on the
table a central part of course if your
message and and I was wondering if you
could clear up whether or not businesses
in Northern Ireland will have to fill
out forms if they want to export to the
rest of the United Kingdom under the
brexit deal because if we just have a
little look there seems to be a bit of
confusion on this because this is what
Boris Johnson has said the Prime
Minister this is what he said
to businesses in Northern Ireland on the
7th of November there will be no forms
no checks no berries of any kind you
will have unfettered access then if you
have a look at the brexit secretary
Stephen Barclay on the 21st of October
he said exit summary declarations as in
the forms will be required in terms of
Northern Ireland 2 GB so he's right I
think the Prime Minister is absolutely
right I think that the whole point of
the deal is that we want to have
frictionless a frictionless border but
at the same time we want to leave the EU
I mean that's the conundrum but us from
outside we want to have as little
bureaucratic interference as possible I
think what the prime minister said is is
absolutely on the money so Stephen Bach
is wrong there won't be exit summary
declarations as far as I understand I
don't think there will be I think the
Prime Minister is absolutely right ok so
and the breaks that secretaries got it
wrong then well I think you have to ask
him but I think that the Prime Minister
knows his deal I mean you negotiated it
ok
and even on takeoff of other issues
they've been in the news this week and
if we whine back to the conservative
leadership party at campaigns will
remember that moment when such a Javid
who was running for the leadership at
the time called on the other candidates
to commit to an investigation into
Islamophobia in the Conservative Party
and the other candidates including Boris
Johnson acknowledged that that would
happen is there going to be in the
inquiry into Islamophobia in the concept
at all I think there's an inquiry that's
going to take place on all forms of
discrimination and Prejudice it's not
just about Islamophobia even though that
is extremely serious but the party while
there's still a long way to go the party
has actually got a good record on this
Sajid Javid himself is of Islamic
heritage he's the chance of the
Exchequer we have many number of Muslim
ministers and we've got a good record on
this on this question of integrating
populations and communities but what I
would say is that any form of
discrimination any form of prejudice is
completely unacceptable and we want to
root it out I mean one person who
doesn't necessarily agree that you have
got a good record on this is the former
Conservative Party chair so you devar
see who expressed her disappointment
that this inquiry as she sees it is not
going to take place
Hanne court yesterday said that others
take more of a balanced approach to
Islam of favor in the Conservative Party
than she did she then accused him white
splaining is not a good look not a great
look it's not good there's no there's no
question of balance any form of
Islamophobia any form of racism any form
of discrimination it's simply wrong and
we want to come down very hard on that
it's not acceptable in terms of the
inquiry my understanding is that we will
have an inquiry but it'll be much
broader than just this question of
Islamophobia I think there was all sorts
of discrimination that's out there you
just have to look at things that people
tweet it's a very vicious world out
there in social media and we have to
make sure that in this party in the
Conservative Party we can stamp all of
that out just finally I just wanna ask
you about something that Boris Johnson
said this week when he was writing about
the Labour Party this is what he said
that this is on the front page of The
Daily Telegraph the tragedy the modern
Labour Party under Jeremy Corbyn is that
they detest the profit motive so
viscerally they point their fingers at
individuals with a relish and a
vindictiveness not seen since Stalin
persecuted the kulaks hmm now the
estimates are that Stalin killed up to 5
million Culex who were these wealthy
wealthy peasants of the 1920s this is a
deeply pressu past so the comparison was
about the philosophy and the Marxism
nobody is suggesting that Jeremy Corbyn
is going to line people up and shoot
them nobody's suggesting that he was
making a point about the philosophy
about the Trotskyism well Stalin was a
Stalinist but the Marxism Leninism the
hatred of capitalism the hatred of
wealth creation
Ian Austin himself Ian Austin was a
Treasury Minister was a minister under
Gordon Brown he said that Jeremy Corbyn
seized wealth creators and wealth
creation as the enemy that was the point
that job Boris was the Prime Minister
Boris was making he was saying that the
philosophy the underlying thinking
behind what jeremy corbyn believes is
very similar to that in the Soviet Union
under Stalin I mean I'm just looking at
what he raves a vindictiveness not seen
since Stalin persecuted the kulaks
colonies persecuted the cool acts the
he didn't believe in wealth creation he
didn't believe that they should be
allowed to make money healed them as
well he didn't just make them pay more
money he didn't believe that they should
make money and Boris's analogy people
can see that was about the philosophy in
the Marxism it wasn't saying and nobody
thinks that kuben is gonna kill anybody
okay let me be very clear about that
thank you very much be on the program
today we are now at time appreciate that
quasi contain there